this video is sponsored by brilliant
the English alphabet contains 26 letters
a b c d e or well you know the rest it's
one of the very first things you learn
in school after all and it seems like an
eternal fact these 26 letters represent
all the sounds the English language has
to offer
or does it thinking about it for a
second you probably realize that no the
English alphabet doesn't contain all the
sounds of the English language and
that's because it's not the English
alphabet really but the Latin alphabet
or at least the version of the Latin
alphabet we English speakers use well in
the Middle Ages there were many English
speakers who realized this fact too and
started to expand the writing system
at one point the alphabet had almost 30
letters and so in this video we'll go
over the seven forgotten letters of the
English alphabet
[Music]
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
brilliant so I'm a history buff as I'm
sure you've noticed I love learning
about history and social sciences but
recently I've been looking more and more
into computer science I use a computer
for my job every day and so I wanted to
learn more about these science that goes
into them well it just so happens that
today's sponsor has helped me do just
that and it can help you too brilliant
is the best way to learn math data
science and computer science
interactively and it's perfect
regardless of your skill level it
customizes its content to fit your needs
so whether you're a student a hobbyist
or a seasoned professional brilliant is
for you to try everything brilliant has
to offer free for a full 30 days and get
20 off their annual plan visit
brilliant.org the generalist papers or
click on the link in the description so
don't wait click the link below now and
start taking your math and science
skills to the next level thanks again to
brilliant and now back to the video
so most of these letters came about in
Old English the version of English
spoken from the 6th Century with the
settling of England by the Anglo-Saxons
to around the end of the 11th century
after the Norman conquest or they came
about in Middle English the version of
English after the Norman Conquest till
around the late 15th century
so let's start with the letter Thorne
this is probably the most well-known
lost letter because of signs like this
if you know anything about this topic
this is old news but this why in the Yi
here isn't actually a y no instead it's
a stand-in for the letter Thorn which
makes the th sound so no this doesn't
say ye old shock instead it says the old
chop we'll get to why this letter y is
there instead of the thorn in just a
second but first let's look at Thorns
history Thorne came into use in Old
English and was borrowed from the Norse
Rune of the same name it survived into
Middle English but by that point scribes
had started using the Digraph th for the
sound probably because Thorne looked too
much like a p it died out almost
completely by the 14th century and was
only used for certain common words like
V and that and that takes us back to the
Yi old sign when movable type printing
was introduced in the 15th century the
typesets English printers bought from
the continent specifically from the
Netherlands and Belgium didn't include
the letter Thorne so English printers
used the y character instead
readers of English at the time would
have understood that in some cases
through context the letter Y was to be
read as Thorn with a th sound
but later on this knowledge was lost and
so people still to this day think
old-timey Englishmen would say ye
instead of thee but they didn't
the letter is actually still used in
Icelandic to this day
next we have Ed
this letter also made the th sound like
Thorn unlike Thorne eth was a modified
Roman letter as you can probably tell
it was most prominently used in the 8th
Century but later fell out of favor and
was replaced by Thorne there were
scribes that used both letters however
and there were rules for which to use in
different cases unfortunately these
rules weren't ever standardized you'll
sometimes hear that the eve letter made
the voiced Dental fricative by the way
Dental figurative is the fancy
linguistic name for the th sound while
Thorne made the unvoiced version
examples of the voiced sound are in
words like feather that and the while
the unvoiced is in words like thing
thumb or thunder this makes sense as we
have letters that the note voiced versus
unvoiced consonants in English already
look at V versus F the sounds are
technically made the same way but V is
voiced well F isn't anyway I couldn't
find much evidence that thorn and eve
were actually used this way and if they
were only some scribes in some
monasteries kept to this rule for the
most part they were used interchangeably
for both the voiced and unvoiced
fricatives
next up we have win like Thorn Wynn was
a rune borrowed into Old English from
Old Norse
it represented the wah sound before the
invention of w
well I say that but scribes had been
using two U's or two v's to make the
sound for a long time but some scribes
didn't like doing that so they adopted
win
but win fell out of favor in the 1300s
and was replaced once again with the w
which eventually transformed into the
separate letter w
the last of our consonants was the
letter yog it originated in Middle
English rather than Old English and it
was derived from the insular G which was
a funny way people wrote the letter g in
the Early Middle Ages
anyway yog made a number of sounds most
commonly it either made the ya sound a
good sound or kind of back of the throat
sound like at the end of the Scottish
word luck as in the Loch Ness monster it
fell out of favor in the 14th and 15th
centuries and was replaced with the
Digraph GH which of course still exists
in our current spellings unfortunately
the sound it made became silent so now
we have silent gh's all over English in
words like light thought night through
and so on
next we have two vowels Ash and Ethel
we'll go ahead and start with Ash next
to Thorn this is the most well-known
lost letter around it's as you can see a
combination of A and E the practice of
smushing the two vowels together started
in the late Roman Empire but it wasn't
considered a separate letter until Old
English in Old English it made a sound
between A and E like the ah in cat
nowadays we just use a for this sound
but in Old English a was a more rounded
ah sound like in the word caught Ash is
still used in French Danish Norwegian
and Icelandic but in English it has died
out you may still see it in some words
though like in the names of Old Kings of
England or when a writer is trying to be
fanciful or archaic
now on to Ethel this one is much less
known than Ash but its history is
similar it started as a quick way to
write o and E next to each other in
Latin it made the oi sound like in
choice but once it made its way to
English through French it tended to make
a simple e sound we still see the
remnants of it in certain words like
Phoenix
it was never that widespread honestly
and it died out in Middle English
and last we have a kind of funny one the
long s
now one could argue that this wasn't a
separate letter at all just a strange
way of writing a lowercase s
and that's sort of true but since it was
used along with the so-called short s
the one we exclusively used today I feel
it deserves a mention in this video the
long ass developed all the way back in
Roman cursive where they wrote s like
this but starting at the end of the 8th
Century with the introduction of the
first minuscule script carolingian it
morphed to this again it wasn't just a
different way to write S no both the
long and short s were used together
and a set of complicated rules arose to
denote when to use the long s or the
short s we're not going to go over a
comprehensive list of rules but here are
some of the basics short s is used at
the end of a word
short s is used before or after the
letter F although not if the word is
hyphenated
long s is used initially and medially
meaning at the beginning or within a
word except for the exceptions noted
above
double s is normally written as double
long s medially and as long s followed
by short S at the end of a word
the long s was used for quite a long
time if you ever find yourself perusing
books from the 18th and even 19th
centuries you're sure to run into it
here you can see it in the United States
Constitution the long as started dying
out at the beginning of the 19th century
and by the 20th century it was
completely gone the reason for this was
that in the printed word the long s
simply looked too much like a lowercase
f
so those are the seven lost letters of
the English alphabet I hope you enjoyed
the video are there any of these letters
that you think should make a comeback
let me know in the comments below thanks
to brilliant for sponsoring and if you'd
like to support the Channel please
consider donating to my patreon the link
is in the description bye
[Music]
thank you